my journey started in 1982
in the financial services industry i
worked in computer operations
and in networking but in 2019
after 26 years i was laid off on my job
here i was in my late 50s and i noticed
there was gaps
in my resume i needed to upskill myself
hi i am christopher palucci i have taken
pmp agile scrum master and idle
certifications from simplylearn
i could find another job because of new
skills i have gained
i chose to upskill myself because it was
essential
compete for a new job in these times and
to become updated with new skills
because the market
absolutely demanded it i wanted to have
project management skills as well as
take up bigger projects
i went on the internet i did searches
for
project management courses
to see what could make me succeed what
what what's the best skill for me to
take up i tried to look at different
courses and different companies that
offered
programs but let me say this to you i
came upon
simply learn and wow simply learn
offer the best value i love to play
piano
i also work out a lot and so
simply learn gave me the opportunity to
learn
on the go and learn whenever i wanted
their on-demand classes their mobile app
made
learning so much more
accessible and enjoyable the instructors
were very knowledgeable
and they were very helpful so it really
helped me to
nail down what i needed to learn the
certificates
helped me because when i was looking for
work
i noticed that i had deficiencies in my
resume
there was gaps that needed to be filled
and the certificates definitely helped
i used them on my linkedin profile and
when i went for an interview
and i went on many i definitely
mentioned
my certificates and the fact that i
completed them so i'm sure that helped
me
after all the searching i finally
was given the opportunity to work at a
company
that does cloud faxing cloud email
and cloud edi i help customers on a
daily basis
achieve their goals i really love the
job
and i have to say because we you are a
company that uses agile on a daily basis
the experiencing working with simply
won't help me
my advice for you young learners is
continue to upskill yourself
continue to update yourself and
help people that need help is no greater
joy when you're helping
people succeed when you help them
succeed
you succeed